Uh,
thanks to everyone who's joining us on
the livestream and who was able to come
in person.
I'm Joelle Common Office.
I am the host and I'm looking up at
the camera there. Uh, I'm a Googler,
I'm a product manager and
I'm an aspiring parent. Uh,
that means that maybe sometime
next year if everything goes well,
I'd like to have kids and I start
early when I prepare for anything.
So my wife and I went to
this talk that she found, uh,
by these characters and fat to introduce.
And uh,
they did this talk at whisper and high
school and it was all about parenting.
What she knows is not surprising,
it's the whole point.
But it was also about psychology
and it was also about technology.
Three of my favorite things,
um,
and I find one thing that they usually
have in common is that to the either
uninitiated, uninformed or just to the
aspiring, they can all be kind of scary.
But what I really liked was that
this is not a fear based message.
This is all about hope and prevention
and looking forward as to how can we not
only avoid the pitfalls but in fact
raise our kids higher in the future.
So a quick introduction then. These are
the cofounders of my digital tattoo.
They have some pretty
awesome chops already.
They've talked to a lot
of different people here.
I even have to take
notes on these numbers.
It's been over 14,000 students,
5,000 parents,
400 educators and a hundred schools in
the bay area as well as 800 healthcare
providers all in the
last four years alone.
So they provide education and training
in four key sectors from all of those
schools, families,
corporations and healthcare.
They also just presented at the annual
Rsa Conference where captains of industry,
we're asking questions about how to deal
with their kids privacy and security
worries online. Kind of interesting.
So without too much further ado,
Gloria Moskovitz squeak sweet,
who's been a social worker educator,
program developer and university lecturer
since 81 and Erica Plevin who's been a
family psychologist for over 20 years,
please welcome them and I'm going to
pass it over to them. Thank you baby.
Uh,
Joel,
thank you for inviting us here and thank
you for coming and we recognize you and
felt you in the audience because your
hand was up an awful lot and there was a
tremendous amount of interest. So
we're delighted to be here. Um,
we have had the privilege now of working
with 14,000 plus students all over
California and it's their story we want
to share with you. It's their voices.
There are no textbooks. Anything that
anybody writes is dated immediately.
It's their voices that have
continued to school, us.
And as we have kind of taken this journey
with them over the past five years,
we have learned so much.
And our goal today is to teach you and
take you into what we've learned. So we,
as Joelle said,
we are not fear based.
We really believe in
the power of technology.
We see it being used
incredibly beautifully and
strongly in empowering ways.
So we understand the power,
we watch kids learn,
we watched kids collaborate
with each other,
we watched them feel empowered
in this incredible world.
And we have watched them do amazing
things around creating a kinder world.
They actually call it the kinder net,
but we also recognize
the challenges and the challenges are big.
And we're going to talk about both and
we're going to talk about them without
judgment because it really is,
is the tool is here to stay is what we
do with it and how we choose to support
our kids and using it
ethically and kindly.
So Erica is going to do the first half
and I'm going to do the second half and
we'll have talked for questions
standing
in the right place. Hi everybody. I'm
Erica and I'm the mom of two boys,
one in high school and one in college.
They are huge gamers.
So I've started learning about this way
long ago when they started entering the
world of gaming.
But what I've learned from being a mom
the last 20 years of their life is that
all the skills that I have offline,
being a good parent and thinking about
things really translate into their online
world,
and that oftentimes we get fearful and
frozen about what they're doing online.
And if we step back and actually just
think about how we parent or how we liked
what our parents did to us,
there's some beautiful translation.
So we're going to talk
a lot about that today.
I thought I'd start with a story that
can help ground us in the importance of
what it is to parent in the age of
social media or parents in the age of
technology.
When my son was in the fifth grade,
I decided to have a pool party.
I was really excited.
It was back in the time when
I felt like I was the manager.
I got to pick all the friends
that could came. Oh, sorry.
that came to the party.
I got to decide what the
theme was. Um, but parents,
I wanted to be around and I hired
a lifeguard and I hired a lifeguard
particularly to stay in the deep end of
the pool because my fifth grader is a
risk taker and I thought,
okay,
something's going to happen in that
deep end of the pool. So I hired a risk,
a lifeguard right in that
spot in the deep end,
in the middle of the party.
I walked in and there was a child
drowning in the shallow end of the pool,
right in that space.
I think we've all been where we can't
feel our feet anymore and all of a sudden
we get that panicked feeling
and he slipped under and
I had to jump in and save
him and take him out. He was okay. The
kids were really upset about watching,
but when the mom came, I
think I had a real attitude.
I'm sure I did. I'm like, uh,
excuse me.
Does your kid know how to swim?
You left them here with no
supervision? And she said, no,
but my kid is so good.
He never leaves the step.
He never goes anywhere. He just
stays in that shallow area. So, um,
when when she left,
Gloria and I started to talk about it
processes and we realize that it's similar
to life in the digital age,
that most of the time our kids are in
that shallow and doing beautiful things
and making safe and good
choices once in a while.
And I think it's sort of their job, um,
to get curious and to go a little deep or,
or to get pulled into what's happening
in that deep end of the pool.
And that's sometimes the slip
under without even knowing it.
And really what we need
is to be their guides,
to be their teachers and to
get in the pool with them.
Now I know that I never liked getting in
a bathing suit or getting into the pool,
but I knew that it was really important
that I got in there because you can't
just throw your kid out there
without learning how to swim.
We're going to have to hold on to them,
teach them the rules of the road when
they actually don't mind having US help
them when they're
interested in being with us.
And then in my opinion now with high
schoolers and kids in college is to move
away and become that consultant.
Help them self regulate an
advocate for themselves.
So when they go out in the world,
they can do that without our assistance.
But if we freak them out so much in the
beginning we've seen that kids are less
likely to come to their parents when
they feel like they've made a mistake.
And I think Gloria and I are real
believers that we want our kids to make
mistakes on our watch because
then we can help them.
We don't want to have
everything so perfect for them.
Snow plow the way for them that they
don't make any mistakes, it's their job.
So I just want to put that out there,
that it's a good metaphor to think about
that we want you there in the pool with
them no matter what age they are.
The kids we've talked to tell us that
they want their parents to hear what
they're saying and to supervise them,
but we're going to talk a
lot about strategies we've
heard over the last couple
of years. Some of them may stick
with you, others might not be.
Things that work with your kids.
Kind of want you to think of it like
a big colander and I'm going to,
we're going to throw a lot at you and
some things will stick and you'll say,
yeah,
I'm going to try that or that might work
with my kid and other things may not
have anything to do with your kid.
But I think what's important for Gloria
and I to convey to you is that you are
the expert of your kid.
I always kind of say find the book that
says what you wanted to say and follow
it because you know your kid,
you are the expert.
If you see that things are going poorly,
you step in offline and what we want
to remind you is that the same is true
online so kids don't really
see an on and an offline life.
They just see it as an is there
rarely leaving their phones behind.
They're usually attached to them.
And so what we find is that if your
kid is experiencing trouble offline,
gender identity, depression,
friendships, sitting alone at school,
any of those things that
are happening offline,
you can be pretty sure that it's going
to follow them into their online life.
Now,
that's not necessarily terrible cause
sometimes they're going into their online
life to look for support or to help
diagnose themselves or to find something
that's gonna make them feel better.
But for us to keep in mind that if we're
worried about our kids offline to check
out what that looks like in their,
in their digital space,
the same is true for their
passions and interests.
I've watched my kids just expand in
things that they're interested in.
They become world experts.
Alex had figured out a way to apply to
all the schools that had a scholarship
for east sport gaming.
That's certainly didn't come to me.
He went out there and he found it himself.
So our kids are really taking what
they're good at and getting better on it
online.
So I think that's important to remember.
Gloria and I often get asked
our kids addicted to technology.
And I think kind of, I'm trying to
answer that question for myself.
Am I addicted to technology?
I'm finding it harder and harder to
leave my device behind because we're here
for an hour.
I'm going to give you our general guiding
principle about whether we're your kid
is addicted to technology and for us it's
a simple question of is it opening up
their world or is it shutting it down?
So I have one very shy kid
and it opened up his world.
He tried on behaviors that he would never
have tried offline and then was able
to practice leadership roles
and take it offline. Uh,
he met friends with similar interests
and he has virtual play dates where he
feels loved and respected.
Um,
but we've also seen it where it
can close down people's worlds,
where they get so invested in finding the
next slide or feeling relevant that it
can close down their world
and make things uncomfortable.
So pay attention to that. Pay attention
to how you're seeing them use it.
Because not all screen
time is the same for us.
It really depends on what they're doing
and how they're using it, balancing it.
But I do want to remind us, I think this
is so important and it seems so simple,
but every time I come back to this,
it's a good reminder when we
talk with the kids we work with,
but also with my own kids,
that kids are kids that really nothing's
changed in terms of team development,
that they're actually doing exactly
what they're supposed to be doing to be
these incredible curious beings when,
when they start to grow up.
So I want to remind you that the teens
are using social media to do all the
things that they're supposed to do.
They're socializing with their peers
like we did. My mom used to ask me like,
how come you come back from school and
you're immediately on the phone? You know,
I was,
I had a cord back then,
but I immediately went to the phone and
they're doing exactly what they should
be doing.
Most of the kids we work with actually
tell us that the reason their socializing
online so much is because there's so
overscheduled that they need these little
bits of time to connect
with their friends.
And I find that so fascinating because
they're telling us we need our community,
we need to stay connected and
we're finding ways to do that.
So they're also trying
on incredible identities.
And Gloria,
Mia and I just got this Bitmoji APP.
Anybody familiar with it where you
can make an Avatar of yourself?
One of the kids suggested it to us
and you put all these outfits on,
have you seen it? And, and it,
it can be really silly and fun.
I think our kids are doing that kind of
like how I used to play dress up or try
out a new ideas when
I went out to parties.
So our kids are really trying
on new identities as well.
But most of all what our kids are doing
is trying to establish independence.
And part of what I think happens in
this new paradigm where we don't know
exactly what the roadmap is,
is to parent,
is we start pulling back and trying to
hover over them and their job is to keep
moving away from us.
So if we can do that in a way where we
can stay curious and they can start to
take those risks and gain independence
and we're not hovering over them,
I think we're really giving
them the greatest gift,
which is to start being critical thinkers.
And I will tell you that
when we're in the classroom,
our kids from ages fifth grade up are
going to be the ones to come up with the
solutions.
When we ask them for solutions about how
to manage group texts or how to manage,
uh, their sleep, they come
up with incredible ideas.
So we really need to use
them and harness their power.
But for the most part,
I want to say they're really
using them in incredible ways.
They're using them to connect to support.
We've even seen kids doing causes
for other kids in their school.
They're using it for schoolwork.
They're collaborating,
they're creating youtube videos.
I mean,
I can't tell you how excited a group of
fifth graders gets when we come in to
talk to them and are curious about what
they're doing because they're doing such
amazing things.
But at some times our kids are
slipping under like in my pool,
um, scenario and making those
mistakes. And sometimes as a parent,
and I'm sure this was true for our
parents to, they, we keep saying, well,
we told you that already, or Oh,
come on, I have to say that again.
We already talked about this
and they're slipping under.
And I'm wondering if anybody knows
why they're slipping on onion,
why are kids slipping under?
Why do we have to tell them so many times
they're actually missing something in
this area that makes it really hard.
We've given them this incredible
tool with incredible power,
both to take care of themselves
and their reputation,
but also to hurt and harm other
people's reputations and feelings.
And they're kind of missing something,
which is that their frontal lobe,
which helps them with that long term
planning and consequences isn't fully
developed.
And for me that's a huge takeaway that
we're asking them to do something without
literally having what they need to do it.
So for us,
sometimes we need to talk with the kids.
We're talking about what's this
going to affect you like tomorrow?
Or how is this going to affect you this
afternoon? Because telling a kid, oh,
you know, if you put that out
there in 10 years from now,
when you have an employer looking at it,
they're not going to like it.
It's really kind of hard for someone
who's lobe isn't developed. Um,
and of course with our teenagers are
middle schoolers and our high schoolers,
their emotions are so high.
And those of you that have kids will
know or go back to when you were that age
that you can be happy and sad and silly
and Matt and anxious and left out in,
in a whole day.
And so when you have a powerful
tool and a bunch of feelings,
we have to really be lending them our
frontal lobe about how to deal with it.
And that all those feelings are normal
and they make sense and they're easy for
us to look at and say like, Oh, come
on, get over it. There's no problem.
But to them, they feel really real.
They change rapidly, and I always say,
if we can name it, we containment, so
instead of just shutting off the device,
if we can start helping our kids
to say, I felt left out, or I'm,
I don't feel like I measure up
or my body doesn't look right,
then we're giving them this huge service
to talk about what they're experiencing.
I want to talk a little bit about this
evolving landscape and Gloria and I used
to just call it the digital landscape
and we realize that working with kids
every day that really it evolves
as soon as we know about it,
something new is coming up and
I think that's probably like,
we like this work so much because
it's constantly changing and areas of
interests keep moving,
but I wanted to tell you a little bit
about what we're seeing in the last six
months or so about what's happening
on this digital landscape.
For tweens and teens.
I think this actually even relates to
us as I think about how I'm starting to
use media more and more.
The first thing we're seeing is that
kids are stuck trying to stay relevant.
And many of our kids will tell us that
they're trying to curate their life to
make it look a certain way to their
friends and the people around them.
And I just want to take a minute to think
about how exhausting that is to have
to lead a curated life.
To have to think that there's strategic
times that you need to post in order to
stay relevant, are not forgotten. And
that that news feed happens so quickly.
Are those texts come so frequently
that if you miss that opportunity,
you're not going to be noticed in,
you're going to be left behind. Now,
this is not true for all of our kids,
but many of our kids will tell us that
they will put a post up and if it doesn't
get enough likes,
they'll take it down. Uh,
they will tell us that they know
their prime posting time that uh,
I get my most likes at eight o'clock or
that they feel upset that they spent the
whole weekend trying to make it look
like a life they had a life and no one
noticed. So just really sinking
into that idea that our,
that our kids aren't having to search
to stay relevant and how that must be so
perfect conversation with our
nieces or nephews, our kids,
our friends is to talk about how we don't
want to define ourselves based on the
number of likes that we get and really
kind of going to do what our parents did,
which is searching underneath
to see what's important
and what we like about our
self without people needing to
give us the praise for that. Uh,
the one on the top is my son and I put
it up there because he is a virtual gamer
and he spends lots of
his time in his room,
in multiplayer environments
with people all over the world.
He's joined teams all over the world.
He has friends all over the world and I
don't know if any of you have had this
experience, but if you're on
what's called a virtual hangout,
you can't say play date once
they leave elementary school,
but when you're on this virtual hangout,
it's pretty incredible.
It feels like everybody's in the room.
I think when I started,
I used to think they're
just in parallel play.
How can this be any kind of interaction?
They're just on their devices now I'm
seeing that they're interacting as a team
and they're doing what I see is engaging
in some pro social games where they're
learning some pretty incredible
skills about community guidelines,
about friendships,
about how to stick up for somebody about
how it feels when someone trolls are
being mean to you.
And that they're actually doing a lot
of this pre-learning as early as fourth
grade in games like Minecraft.
But most of all, and that corner,
right is our advisory board, which
we go to a lot to look for, uh,
advice and to run things by them.
They are socializing with their friends.
And I think most people would look at
that and they would say they're not
socializing,
they're all on their devices and
they will tell us they looked at it,
but they're all talking to each
other or sharing or having fun.
So a reminder that our experience might
not be how they're experiencing and to
talk about,
does anybody remember this?
A whack a mole game.
So the thing that I can't believe I kept
going back to whack a mole is if I was
going to figure it out and I always
wanted to get a higher score and the thing
would come up and go down
and we would get frustrated.
And Gloria and I just thought this was
a perfect image to talk about how it
feels to stay up to date in our kids'
lives with what they're doing online.
And I think as soon as we figure it out,
they've gone somewhere else. I mean,
that's sort of what they're supposed to be
doing, right? If, if we're at the party,
they're going to leave. I
mean, that's embarrassing.
So I don't think our job is really to
have to know exactly what they're doing at
all times,
but our job is to be curious about it,
to see trends that are going on and and
to ask them about what goes on in each
of these sites.
And I put the word down code switching
there because for those of you,
you might even be doing it
yourself cause I certainly do,
but most of our kids will tell us that
they actually have a whole circle of ways
that they go and check their media.
Like they have their Instagram open,
then they'll check their snapchat
and they'll look at reddit.
Then they might do a little Pinterest
for it or which phone game and that they
do this kind of an order and that each
one of those platforms has their own way
of being and so that they have an
amazing ability to code switch between of
those.
I just want to talk about the importance
of opening up the dialogue and for me I
always say be curious.
Not Furious because I think it's so easy
for me to say to my husband, to my kids,
like, what are you doing?
You're wasting your time.
We should be out and
going and doing something.
Well that doesn't really set the tone
for somebody wanting to tell you about
what they're doing.
It's sets the tone for you,
telling them to go outside and then
they take the device and go with their
device outside.
So I'm curious to,
to encourage you to ask your kids,
what are the apps that people are using?
What do you like about them to try it
on yourself today I tried on a new APP.
It was called, uh, musically,
no, it wasn't musically,
but musically is another good example
where we can get on and we can do Karaoke
and we can be playful and fun and really
feel what it feels like to want to do
10 videos instead of just one and to have
a hard time not wanting to fix it and
make it better.
So the more we enter their world,
the more I think we get a sense of what
they're doing rather than being mad.
So let's take a look at the apps
that we're paying attention to. Now.
Our kids have moved away from Facebook.
Any idea why they moved away from
Facebook? We're on it, right?
Or grandmas or taking selfies are,
kids will tell us though
that because you're on it,
they'd like to ask you a favor,
which is to stop posting pictures
of them without their permission.
And I think that's important because it
becomes part of their digital tattoo.
But we're also asking them to do that
with their friends so that the digital
drama decreases.
So kids will tell us like,
I really don't want that picture of me
in the Bathtub Nudie when I'm 12 and says
like,
where have the year's gone that they
really want you to model and ask them for
permission.
I'm just thinking that all of these
apps for me have good intention.
I don't think any apps are
created to be mean or bad.
What we know is when teens go anywhere
in a large number that things get sexual
and that they push the envelope.
And so I guess I wanted to talk
just briefly about each of these.
Maybe just not all of them but about
what kids are finding amazing about them,
but also some of the things you might
want to start talking about or thinking
about when you're
talking about these apps.
So they are moving away from
Facebook. Like we said, they
checked birthdays there,
they made check maybe
communication with relatives,
but it's not the space that
they're hanging out in.
I wondered if anybody knew.
Let's just pick one of these up here.
Anybody know kick? Yeah. So
what do you know about Kik?
So, so we love it that it's
a messaging APP. We love it,
that it's free and that
kids can get to use it.
And what we also know is that when you
take your kids phone away and you think
that they're not going to
be texting anymore, that
they're getting the free kick.
Gac. Yeah. And then
they're able to use that.
I'm also going to point,
I got the five minutes sign that
the right is called followers. Plus.
What I think is interesting about that
is that it takes analytics of how you're
doing with your postings and want you to
think about that with your kids to see
did someone unfriend you, did they not?
What's my top posts really to talk about?
That's really important.
Ooh,
is that group chat where our kids get
to be together in a group formation.
Anytime we're in a big group, we run
the risk of mean behavior happening.
Uh,
periscope and some of the other live
apps are a place where we're seeing a lot
of problems because kids aren't really
thinking with their frontal lobe.
And so they're exposing things quickly
in the moment and not pulling back to
think about it.
And the only thing I wanted to say
about Instagram and snapchat is that
Instagram, um, your, your kids
have two Instagram accounts.
We're pretty sure of it now that one is,
they're curated one for their family and
one is their real one that they share
with your friends. So talk about it.
Same thing about snapchat is fun,
exciting, really playful. They
don't have to be picture perfect,
but there's lots of room for people to
feel left out of situations to feel like
things are happening in live
time and they're not included.
We've also had this amazing shift from
real name to anonymous culture and it's
like our kids are listening to us.
We asked them to be careful when you
put your name out there so they went
underground.
So the three that have come into play
love you to ask your kids or nephews or
nieces if they know them and how you see
them being affected is the afterschool
APP ASK FM and the burn book.
So really talking about the
power of anonymous APPS,
how we can be a little
meaner behind a screen,
how much more we have to focus on stepping
in someone else's shoes to be able to
really feel that when we don't see them.
On the other side of the screen,
I want to tell you about this incredible
thing that we keep hearing about with
kids, which is how much these
gurus and viners are their friends,
how much they look up to them,
how much they wait for the
next video to be released,
and how much information
they can give us to,
how are kids doing to kind
of get a psychological pulse
on how they're doing in
the world, what they're gravitating
to, what they're interested in.
So I love just asking kids who are your
favorite youtubers or viners and why?
And you get incredible answers.
The middle one is Pewdie Pie.
The top is, um, I call him the,
the Mr. Rogers of Minecraft. His
name is stampy long nose. Uh,
there's Jenna marbles
at the bottom. Um, so,
and Miranda Miranda sings at the
bottom and Jenna marbles in the middle.
But I want you to think the same way you
did about asking your kids about their
friends in elementary school.
I want you to ask them about the people
they're watching. How'd you meet,
how did you get introduced to them?
What's interesting about them, hey,
let me take a look at it. Instead
of saying, oh, I don't like them,
or they're no good, we actually just
talk about what they're interested,
why and sit down and we can
learn so much about them.
Our kids tell us that they want us to
supervise them, not supervised them.
That they don't want you to take their
phone away at night and look at what
they're doing.
They want you to go through it with them
because they're creates a feeling of
anxiety. If they know that you're
always kind of overlooking them.
We want to tell you that we rarely see
predators and we know parents worry a lot
about predators. Um, and if your
kid is struggling with issues,
then you may see that.
But for the most part,
the dramas happening with their friends.
Ask your kids,
what's the digital drama happening
right now in your squad of friends? Um,
we want to look for openings for
connection and discussion. So in my life,
I send my kid, I used to send him
a note to his lunchbox. I love you.
Now I send a note to his inbox or quit,
so and give them an
out of hard situations.
So I'm going to end with this one
and then hand it over to Gloria.
But I think this feels like my
most important slide, which is,
and I think Gloria started with this,
which is I think that the tool is
here to stay and has incredible power,
but just taking it away without having
a conversation leaves them just wanting
to go underground. So for example,
if we don't like in my house,
I don't like to single person shooter
games and I can say I don't like it cause
I think it desensitizes you to
violence. Uh, or you can say,
I'm worried about your sleep.
Or you can say,
I feel like in those musically videos
you're sexualizing yourself to get
attention.
And,
and so instead of taking away the
APP or taking away the device,
I'm going to encourage you to have
the conversation, to be curious,
to enter their world, to hear
what they have to say. Uh,
and to kind of think back on our parents
and when they were open to knowing what
we were doing without shutting us down.
It was the time we made the
best connections and then
we can send our kids up
being self advocates.
All right.
It is um, been such an incredible
gift for me to work with Erica and uh,
to really look at what triggers
us so much as a psychologist,
as a clinical social worker.
We were really intrigued by the psychology
of technology and we want to take you
into this, into this place that we
have been in for the past five years.
But to do that,
I'm going to ask you all to go back to
middle school and I'm just curious how
many of you would go back to
middle school if you could?
Not a single hand is going up here.
Very rarely do we see hands go up here.
Can anyone tell me why
they wouldn't go back?
Like why would you not
go back to middle school?
Puberty. Yeah. Selfconsciousness just the,
I mean like the light is on you and
everybody's watching. Absolutely.
So let's go into this right now.
Actually, I want you to, as you go back,
I want you to remember when and in doing
that, even if you're not a parent yet,
I mean, Joel, when you talked about it,
you were thinking about what
it would mean to be a parent.
So the best way to do this is
to think back at this time. So
let's remember one,
how many of you remember doing and note
that looks something like this? You know,
so we all had a version of something like
this and this was very important to us
as we were defining ourselves. And the
most important thing was to be liked.
We all want it to be liked,
we wanted everyone to approve of us.
And it's really no different is
it? It is still. Do you like me?
And as Erica mentioned, our kids are,
well not completely off Facebook,
but getting off of Facebook,
it's about insta likes and it's about
evaluating yourself worth by the number of
likes and by the number of comments.
And we've had so many conversations with
kids about this and it's been really an
eye opener for us to have them talk
about what it means to really get social
collateral,
a social currency by the number of likes
they get and the number of comments and
how strategic they are about that
and how careful they are about that.
And what we say to parents is that
this is such an incredibly important
conversation.
If you see your child completely
defining themselves by those likes.
And by the way, I'm going to talk about
my own kids around this. You know,
in one of my oldest son would say to me,
in spite of my best self at the age of 29,
I cannot stop looking at how many
likes I'm getting on Instagram.
So we all know that pool.
And I want you to imagine that pool on
steroids because for kids to be liked in
middle school is what they are all about.
And to us that is the
discussion that we want to have.
And we also want to look at
it for ourselves too. Um,
but definitely look at it with our kids
that appreciate that this is a time when
it's really,
really huge for them.
What to talk about the impact of social
media on the adolescent brain and as we
talk about this,
we're,
we're going to be looking at generalities
and we're going to be looking at what
we know about the brain and we're also
going to be talking about what we have
learned and what kids have
shared with us as well.
So we know that our brains are hardwired
to seek new information that is no
different.
We literally get a shot shot of dopamine,
the happy chemical with an in
today's world with a, with a text,
with a tweet, with the, like with the
buzz. We get this search, and again,
imagine this in middle school
because it's far bigger.
It's a much more intense search.
What our kids are saying to us is
that their texts and tweets are highly
perishable and they lose that social value
if they're not responded to instantly.
This has been an interesting transition
for us in this field because what was
five years ago?
An acceptable amount of time.
Can anyone guess what an acceptable
amount of time might've been about three
years ago to respond to a text?
Good
a day.
What do you think it is now?
Not even,
it's for many of our kids,
they talk about wanting an
immediate response and if
they don't get an immediate
response,
they will think that something has
happened like dreadful to their part,
to that person. They've even said
to us, maybe they're dead. We've,
we've heard kids say that.
Or they think that something,
they've done something terribly wrong and
therefore that person's not responding.
So that that response time
has shifted enormously.
And I think it's a shifted for
every adult I now as well. I mean,
there's no question about that.
They also let us know that, that,
that the fact that it's highly perishable
makes this device so incredibly
important. 24, seven because they're
out of there. They're not in the know.
If they don't have it, they
often will say to us, um,
if I don't respond to a friend right away,
she's gonna think I'm a really bad
friend and that means my call is to be 24
seven and always there.
And that imperative is
incredibly important to look
at because that's a really
tough way to live. And we see
a lot of our kids, I would say,
well it's not just our girls,
it's girls and boys really struggling
with this issue of being always on.
Let's continue thinking about what this
biology is and like let's look at some
of the chemicals that are
going on in the brain.
Dopamine is one of these key chemicals
that we know about scientifically,
but we're also hearing
about it a lot for our kids.
Of course they're not talking
about it in terms of dopamine,
but they are saying it feels
really good to connect it.
It makes them feel like they
are really in the know and they,
and they are really loving
that constant connection.
And we're talking about brain chemistry
because it's dopamine that gets
stimulated by tiny bits
of new information,
which is exactly what social media is.
So we can see the pool for this.
And there were also
talking about oxytocin,
which is what's called
the cuddle chemical,
and it releases a feeling
of goodwill and connection.
And that's what the comments are about.
That's what the likes are about.
And that's what's really getting
highlighted in the eye and the brain of an
adolescent and not just the brand of an
adolescent, the brain, all of our brains.
So between dopamine and between oxytocin,
it's really hard to stop wanting more
and we can really see that pool that our
kids are experiencing. And by the
way, that we're all experiencing,
I don't know anybody that is completely
honest that wouldn't say I'm feeling the
tug of this as well.
But we know that for our kids,
because of their brain chemistry,
it's more so than it is for adults.
So that's her advisory group again.
And with that in mind
with sort of the brain,
very brief look at brain chemistry,
would you say that kids
are addicted to devices?
And I'm just curious
about a show of hands.
How many of you would say kids
are addicted to devices? Okay, so
some hands are going up. How many of
you would say your addicted to devices?
I think I am. You're on
the fence? Not quite sure.
So we're going to look at two ways of
looking at this. And I want to say to you,
this is without judgement at all.
As a mom, I didn't mention earlier,
I'm the mom of three
young adults and it's,
they have led me through
this world and the work.
All of our kids have really
taught us so much about this.
And this is what we're seeing and hearing.
Our kids are saying to us,
we're not addicted to our phones.
We just like each other.
And it had overscheduled intense world
where there's so much expected of them
and they have to move so quickly.
Those times that I know,
are you a member of just space where
I could ride my bike and no one was
watching me and I didn't
have to text my mom.
I can't even imagine that as an
adolescent those days are over.
So what it means to be tethered to their
parent is huge and and they are missing
that and they really don't have that
time to play the way they used to.
So they're using a device to connect
into play because that need to connect as
no different than what any of us had.
What we also have seen very clearly
is face to face conversation begins.
We're digital ones and and vice
versa that there is no honor off.
It's exactly the same.
It's one world and that both
really contribute to that
formative development of
identity.
They're both incredibly important.
So that's sort of one perspective and
looking at this and then we're also seeing
another,
we talked about the power and we talked
about the challenges and so I'm going to
look at the challenges right now.
This is a quote from one of our 12th
grade students. You're not alone.
When you're on your phone and we're
seeing that ability to be alone really
shifting.
And I know when I take a walk,
I very rarely see someone alone anymore.
I mean there is a device going on,
there's a full conversation happening.
So we are struggling with
what it means to be alone.
And that's an interesting issue when
you think about invention and new,
um,
new energy often comes out of that alone
time and we're seeing less of that now.
And that's an interesting
thing to ponder on. So again,
this is our advisory group and if
we look at them, we see sort of,
this is a very typical discussion with
our kids and you see them kind of on
there. There's a phone there, there's
conversation and you see a head down.
And that's not uncommon at all.
And what we are hearing and what we're
seeing from our kids and for most people,
and here's the conversation we had
with one of our kids. That quote,
if a phone is on the table,
I will keep my conversation light
knowing I don't have full attention.
Then in that at any minute some will be
distracted and I think that is a very,
very true issue and that has shifted.
That is something very different.
We didn't hear that five years ago.
We are seeing that now.
If the phone is on the table,
I will keep that conversation light and
I'm not going to go deep because I know
at any minute I'm going to lose attention.
That was an 11th grade student.
Our kids are learning this new
social norm in middle school.
They're learning it when they are
learning how to look like they're paying
attention to a lecture and they're
texting underneath their desk.
They're learning that they can pull this
off and pull it off really, really well.
So we're watching our kids feel that
this is something they can absolutely do.
But the question that I think we have to
address is are we losing the complexity
of what it means to be in a conversation?
Because conversations are complex and we
have to know and we have to be able to
tolerate that awkward
silence when you're not sure,
is it my turn to talk or
is it their turn to talk?
We have to figure out where to stand in
space and am I too close? Am I too far?
When do I make eye contact?
When do I look down?
This doesn't happen if a
child is looking at a device.
And this personally gives us concern
because what we know is that those skills
are still needed. It
doesn't matter. You know,
our world is here to stay.
Our World of media is here to stay.
But those skills are human skills.
And I think it's important for us to all
pay attention to the fact that we are
saying our kids now struggling with
us in a really, really big way.
Many of them are telling us that
they would much rather text, um,
than they would talk because they
can control the conversation.
And if they're talking,
they've lost control of the conversation.
And I think that's an interesting
thing to pay attention to.
Has anyone seen this photograph?
I would imagine some of you have,
it was a photograph sent to
us by one of our advisors. Uh,
it was taken about a year
ago and Redondo beach.
And we are convinced that this man is
googling where to find whales and we're
sure we're sure that he missed
exactly what he needed to see.
And we know that there was a guy in front
of him taking this picture and I had
this fantasy of him screaming,
look up.
I mean just look up and the guy who never
did. So we are tethered and you all,
most of you raised your hands in terms
of your own tethering and our kids are
very honest about that.
We're tethered to our devices.
Our kids are tethered to their friends.
Our kids are tethered and
romantic relationships.
The amount of texts
that go back and forth,
it can be overwhelming and almost
suffocating to many of them in late middle
school and high school. And I want to
talk a little bit about the tethering.
We're saying for parents because that's
a really interesting level of tethering
that has shifted quite a bit.
Um,
we are hearing from colleges now
that there's an expectation not well,
they're seeing that they're his parents
and kids are texting sometimes seven to
eight times a day.
And um,
and the techs can take these
very interesting tourance
they can be things like,
and kids are sharing this with
people at school and college. Um,
can you geo locate the library for me
and you can you geo locate the bookstore
and while you're at it we'd like,
I'd like you to get my books and get them
immediately because I expect things to
happen immediately. So there's a
language and there's a term for this.
Right now our colleges are calling
it drone parenting and it's kind of
fascinating and it's a little
scary when we think about this.
It's helicopter parenting with
tech enhanced surveillance
capacity and expanded
reach.
So they've given,
they move from hover parenting
hovering to drone parenting at college.
What it looks like is arguing with props
on behalf of grilled growing children
for grades. Um, and they also look like
correcting their paper and turning it in.
And a profit is very clear that this
is not coming from a student but coming
from a parent and then let's look at
what it looks like in the world of work.
And I can certainly speak to this as a
parent of kids that are in the world of
work, going to job fairs and bosses,
offices in place have grown children.
And I know for myself,
I see some heads nodding here for myself.
When my oldest son got his first job,
it was amazing for that job to court my
husband and I equally as they courted my
husband with an assumption that
if they wanted him they had,
we had to talk him into it too.
So I'm seeing a shift happening culturally
that's looking like it's normal and
we may not want this to want to be
normal. You guys, I mean this one,
this one gives us big pots.
So drone parenting.
Now I also want to talk about a shift
that we have seen in our five years of
working with kids. And I'm going
to throw this question out to you.
When we ask kids,
we show a short video and it's very old
school about someone being digitally
tethered and,
and losing the losing conversation.
And when we showed them this video,
we asked them who they see,
who do you imagine they see when
we showed this? Any guesses?
You nailed it.
Now that's a shift.
They didn't see their parents before.
They used to see themselves.
And um, we're now in fourth grade.
Primarily we're an elementary school,
high school, Middle School and
high school. And the shift,
I'd say in the last year and a half,
our kids are now saying, that's my mom.
That's my dad.
That's my family.
And I'm going to take you into some of
the quotes that we've been hearing from
kids on this one.
This is a ninth grade student.
If parents stopped for a second to
look behind their iPad and put down the
scream,
they would realize they're kids are right
in front of them and they are trying.
And that's really pretty intense quote.
Um,
we often present this in many ways in
fourth and fifth grade and it's amazing.
Kids are shooting up their hands and
they're sharing strategies with each other
on how they can bring their parents back.
And here are some of the strategies.
Well one child said, I see my dad two
days a week and he's always on his iPad.
The bottom are the strategies kids are
sharing with each other about how they
pull their parents back. I shake them,
poke them, pinch them, bribe them,
yell at them, weigh the piece
of paper in front of their face,
grab their phone away.
Our newest one that we heard is
called them by their full name,
which you thought was hysterical. Uh, put
my face in their face until they see me.
But the one that really concerns us
is that I give up and then they say,
and then I give up and I go in
my room and I got on my device.
And what concerns us is kids in school
still think parents are incredibly cool
and there are looking for connection and
they're looking for a time to have that
icon.
I contacted conversation,
but if they're learning early at
this point that nobody's home,
they are going to just drift away and
they're going to just go to Google to look
up things and not go to their parents.
So this is definitely an issue that
we're seeing and paying attention to.
I also want to talk about
tech not perfection and when
we ask our kids to define
Tecta perfection,
they are really clear that
it's about a curated image.
It's about trying to be
perfect and expecting that
perfection is something they
have to have 24 seven
I was amazed when we do our advisory
groups that we asked in this question,
they could have talked about it
forever and we asked them what are the
acceptable body types and they told
us that it's super skinny or Kim
Kardashians. And if you look at the
new Barbie dolls that have come out,
it's interesting.
Some people,
has anyone been aware of the new barbies
that have come out, go check them out.
They're fascinating to me.
Some of them are looking just like Kim
Kardashians and some of them are looking
just like super skinny and so in a way,
and they thought this was really good
news because it was defining real bodies,
but are they real bodies?
So look at what's going on there.
Our feeling is that this
subliminal message is beauty
is unachievable and we're
hearing our girls talk about this quite
a bit and what we're also very aware of
is that it's not just a girl issue,
that it is a boy issue as well.
So what I want to talk with you about
right now or the kinds of things that our
kids have said to us and our advisory
group about what they want their parents
to do to help. How do we change this?
How do we start this conversation?
And the first thing they said to us is
we want our parents to help us combat
those myths.
Because to us it's real.
We see a billboard or we're
assuming that it's real.
Help us understand that being
thin will not bring you happiness.
I love this one. Helping not seek external
validation. And find my own voice.
Start this conversation early and people
are often very afraid to start the
conversation because they
think it's too young.
There is no too young and
shift the conversation.
What are they trying to sell you?
There is no middle schooler that wants
to be manipulated and once they realize
that someone's trying to sell them
something, especially in adult,
they're going to be able to push back
and as I mentioned earlier,
this one gets them
screaming when we show them.
Justin Bieber can't even really
explain what's going on there.
But what I love about showing us images
that they're not supposed to see the one
over in this corner, they're supposed
to see the really buff to find one.
And what we want them to
get is the manipulation.
We are seeing that because it's a female
issue, it's seen as a female issue.
There are often not able to discuss it
the way that girls do and we want them to
because that conversation is important
and we really love this quote because we
think that pushing back as we really
want our kids to be able to do.
I'm looking at our time and I want to
talk a bit about sleep because sleep is an
enormous issue that's impacting kids and
at first to on this ladder used to have
what our teens are saying about sleep
but we had to change us because of our
kids. It's what our children and our
teens are saying about sleep and it's been
significant.
I closed my eyes and go to sleep and
feel like my brain is on coffee and this
just happened last week.
That was a fifth grade quote and I'm
curious if anybody ever feels like the
brains on coffee in here
when you go to sleep it's
like what is going on?
This is emerging science
and we're starting to get
more information on this and
I'll share with you in brief what
we're saying and what we're learning,
but we are seeing that our kids are coming
to school with digital hangovers and
I can certainly see that adults are going
to work with digital hangovers as well.
What we are finding out is the kids
between the ages of nine and 15 are
especially sensitive to light
exposure in the evening.
Light comes at them from any way
and they're sensitive to all light,
but we're also wondering,
and we're learning that the blue light
emitted from digital devices may be
particularly impactful and we
know it's impactful to us as well.
The more evening light exposure,
the lower that level of Melatonin.
It's true for all of us and
incredibly true for this age group,
so it suppresses their bodies time clock
and makes them fall asleep later and
therefore wake up with those digital
hangovers. So what do we do about this?
And I want to say what
do we do about this?
Because this impacts all of us and these
are just a few things to look at. Um,
is anyone using flux? It's a
great one. And the new iPhone,
um, has niche, it is at night night shift,
which is going to be also mirroring.
We know that blue light tricks
our brain into staying awake.
So flux does this amazing
thing which is so important.
It mirrors our bodies time clock.
It mirrors what our body
needs when it's nighttime,
it turns that reddish glow of the sun
setting. When it's daytime it turns blue.
And there are also really
good apps that we recommend.
Self control is one of them that blocks
access to distracting websites. Um,
stay focused is another that sets a timer
where you can block your own access to
those websites. And re readability is one
that really helps with online clutter.
It's amazing we're having to develop
these tools to help us not get distracted,
but we have to and we have to really
support our kids are doing this as well.
And then finally,
when Eric and I are in schools and
we're really challenged and parents were
encouraging them to change the
norms around 24, seven conductivity,
because we're all feeling it.
So what are the skills our kids
are going to need in the future?
We know that it's the ability to work
cooperatively and collaboratively through
network communication. I mean we, we
see it, we're living it right here.
Collective intelligence, crowdsourcing.
And it's that very sharing,
tweeting, constant updating that's
preparing them to do that work. I mean,
it's that thing that worries us,
that is so incredibly important.
But here's the paradox that here's the
piece that we have to look at with the
world at their fingertips.
It's the ability to tune out the noise
because there's an awful lot of noise out
there and engage in technology
with awareness and balance
that's going to cause
us to be able to succeed this world.
So that's the piece that's
so incredibly important.
And I want to share with you that,
that um,
we are really at a place right now
after working with 14,000 kids and we're
moving very,
very quickly and expanding.
We're looking for partners and we
were looking to expand our reach to
organizations and to schools particularly
where kids can't afford this and we
feel that everybody needs it and we want
to introduce our executive director,
Mia Walker,
who is a former Googler and a,
we will be here for conversation and
really look forward to talking with you if
any strategies and ideas about this.
Thank you so very much for coming.
Thank you for inviting US Joelle.
One thanks guys.
How do you define
acceptable usage of a phone?
And the question came in two parts
and I love it. So I'll read them out.
That datum. Uh, one is, is
it okay to take away phones,
have bad grades and as a follow on,
is it different when they,
or we use the phone just to
research things like, oh,
let me Google that to pick up the phone
and check it out. That kind of thing.
I say something
about taking the phone away
for, for bad grades, I,
the danger of doing that is creating
the forbidden fruit. I mean if,
if we take it away as a punishment,
if you really want to make someone fall
in love with something and make it the
forbidden fruit and I think
that that technique is, is just,
is doomed for failure.
Personally as a parent,
I don't think that that works very well,
that sad.
There's absolute need for limits and our
kids desperately need our limits. Um,
do you have any other thoughts on that?
Yeah.
Thinking the same thing and that sometimes
being part of a conversation ahead of
time,
some preventative work,
talking about a contract or pointing out
what you're noticing that their grades
are slipping or that they're acting
inappropriately in their conversation is a
better way to talk about it than
just grabbing the device away.
Because we will often hear kids say,
oh,
I just get a free counting and used my
friend's phone to text or I have a dummy
phone that I give my parents
and they don't remember.
So I also like kids to really understand
that our bodies are not meant to
multitask,
that we don't do it very well,
that our bodies are in desperate need
of sleep. And none of us do this. Well.
I think that parents have to model this.
I think that if we just direct kids,
but we're also hearing from kids is
parents will say to them, you know,
get rid of that device and as they're
saying that they're on their device and so
that it's not going to,
that will not bode well. Um,
they're really watching our behavior
far more than they're listening to us.
So we have to really be
willing to model it and may be,
that may mean in some families
are doing this, it's 10 o'clock.
All devices are down, including
ours. Not Easy, but that is effective
in my house.
We have forced family fun.
We're all the devices have to
stay at home and we all leave. Um,
just really carving out those digital
free spaces where kids feel like where
there are families are feeling like we're
being heard and that they're important.
Yes,
it's a great idea for everyone to put
their phones down at 10:00 PM but how do
you reconcile that with the needs of
the kids to stay in touch instantly with
our friends who don't put
their phones down at 10:00 PM
you know, we're, we're in an interesting
time right now. I mean, we, we, I mean,
I think his parents, we have to come
together and work as communities. I mean,
that is, that is not easy to do. And
yet it's so important to do. I mean,
I think we have to model it.
I also think it would be so great to
have a community conversation and have
other parents doing it too.
But I remember as a parent being told,
you're the only mom doing this and
I'm so angry at you for doing that.
And it's okay to have that anger because
we're really helping them out of a jam.
What kids say to us privately. They
don't want us to share it with parents,
but I am exhausted and I want off
that group tax, but I can't tell them.
But I'm going to let you know. Um,
and I'm not going to tell my parents,
but you're,
you're helping them out of a jam.
So I'm encouraging parents to set limits.
Yeah.
I'm kind of agreeing with glory.
I've been called the meanest mom Mna in
North America because I wouldn't let a
phones come to a sleepover cause I kind
of feel as my parents did that nothing
good happens after 11 o'clock
when you're in a group, uh,
that it just kind of goes south. But, uh,
my experience has been that we do a super
good job finding out the best tutors,
the best schools,
the best camps,
talking to parents all the
time to gather information.
And that if we could use that same
curiosity and connectedness to say, hey,
you guys,
do you remember when our parents wouldn't
let us call after nine o'clock because
it was rude or answer the phone during
dinner? And it was just an is right.
And so I think the more we talked to
other parents in our kids' friends groups
or to help them do what
Gloria said and realize like,
we're not doing it to be mean,
we're doing it because these devices are
tricking your brain into believing it's
daytime and you don't feel good.
And getting it though.
How many kids actually want to fight
distractions from this question? Uh,
when I was a teen,
I didn't really notice when I was tired
or distracted and I didn't think getting
A's instead of bees was worth
the extra work anyway. No
Kid wants to fight distraction.
I mean they're,
they're not even feeling distracted.
I hope I'm hearing this correctly.
No child would say to you,
they would all say to you,
I am amazing at multitasking.
I could do 20 things at once.
I can do whatever. I mean, but we
all said that too, right? I mean,
I said I could do whatever at any time
because that ability to recognize that
they can't isn't there yet. So we have
to be the ones to say, you know what,
I'm going to help you with this.
It's really not about getting a six.
We're about staying healthy and sane.
I mean,
we can't survive on three hours of sleep.
And I know some kids that are trying,
um, we've heard teachers say that
papers are coming in at 1130,
1230 for fifth graders because they're
getting so distracted that's not working
for anybody.
I have to get their pain point.
And right now what we're noticing in
the classroom is group texts are a pain
point that they go on to several group
texts and then hundreds of k what's
happening, you know, uh,
just flooded their inbox and the
beings and make it hard to go to sleep.
So I put it back on them like,
what can we do about this?
What do you guys think you can do?
And they come up with amazing strategies.
So putting it back into their hands,
uh,
to help is and hitting their
pain point really works.
That's a great segue to the
question I had for you guys,
which is do you know
of or, or anything, um,
groups or meetups for discussions among
parents or between parents and kids or
even among kids with your advisory panel
or anything where people can go in and
share and develop their solutions?
I love that question. Uh, we're, we're,
we're seeing that popping up all over.
So we're seeing schools when we go to
a community and we present to schools,
we're seeing parents afterwards going,
we're going to start something
and we need to start it now.
And they come together as parents did
no differently than we came together
around other issues as an opportunity to
discuss some of our most effective work
has been working with parents separately
and kids separately and then bringing
everybody together to share strategies
with each other, really powerful.
So often it starts small.
It's often parents going on lost and then
coming together with other parents who
equally feel that way. And then just
starting that community conversation.
I love what you're talking about because
we spend most of our time talking about
problems, about facilitating
conversations. About how it feels.
And I love the idea as we start to expand
our program bigger to talk about what
can we do about it?
How do we work as a collective community
to create a kinder Internet where we
have incredible power and we
can do great things. And I, I,
I would just love people to come to
us with ideas and to help these kids
facilitate their own.
So to,
I wanted to say something about our
conversation after we met you. Um,
I'm fired up about parents before they
have children saying we want to do
something now because we're concerned.
And some of the current research,
the new research is coming out around
attachment just a little scary.
So we are encouraging parents to talk
even before they have kids about how they
want to deal with this world. So, uh,
this conversation is incredibly important.
Okay. Well thank you both very
much. We're just about out of time.
Really appreciate you guys coming down
to Google to give us all talk. Thank you.
Yeah.